what's up guys we are the Google pixel 7
Pro with us this thing runs a Google
tensor g2s chipset and it runs an Octa
Core for its CPU and a Mali g710 mc10
for its GPU and you know it's a pretty
Sleek looking phone we even have the
Google pixel 7 here with us which is
comparatively smaller than the pixel Pro
but um we're not gaming this today we're
going to be gaming with the pro so we're
going to be running against impact Apex
Legends Call of Duty and Diablo Immortal
as per usual and before we get into the
gameplay let's just check out the base
temperatures of the phone from the front
and the back
so as you can see the bags are like 27.9
you know pretty normal temperatures in a
room temperature environment we do not
have the icon on so
yep not too bad 28 27 ish degrees on the
back all right now for the front uh 28
29 ish probably 31 30 on there that's
because the display isn't on for a bit
and we are
going to check out this phone we are
currently at 100 battery as you can see
in the top here so let's just get into
the games okay so now we're monster
let's just check outside things I've
already appreciate everything
to the highest for graphics as you can
see high high high everything is on the
highest we had 60 FPS and yeah
everything is everything's on
so let's just walk around one step real
quick
[Music]
nothing much going on here so far no
noticeable frame rate drops
just another note you know it's really
comfortable play on this thing and I can
feel the back heating up a bit
and I get oh what was that also filming
job I think I'm not sure
I had 200 and Playback but yeah
they are no noticeable frame jobs but
uh let's just go out and pick a fight
with someone
see what we have on here
okay
let's go pick a fight
yeah I could see a couple
frame rate drops here and there
just a little bit
yeah you can see that yep
you guys can see that it is dropping a
bit
yeah I know as we all say you know
genjin isn't exactly
best optimize on any kind of mobile
phone so
[Music]
yeah
I forgive my damage but
oh
[Applause]
my
God
damn it
I will say like um registration for the
tapping is a bit weird for some reason
it's a bit I'd say delete all you know
sensitivity is pretty heavy I'm not sure
if I can change it up but I'll just deal
with it for now
hmm
[Music]
foreign
fights behind us I guess I can see you
know it does tend to drop quite a bit in
terms of frame rate and it's not like a
crazy amount but the thing is the
stuttering does kind of impede on the
gameplay like just a little bit not too
much
but the other thing is let's just check
the temperatures real quick because I
can feel the heating up
37 on the front right now oh 40
. it's getting kind of hot yeah let's
check the back
yeah this is really heating up right now
42 440 at the back
yeah it's getting really hot in the back
right now
like you know it doesn't feel like one
ear is just getting the heat it feels
like the Heat's being dissipated around
the back cover of the phone so it's not
that bad anyway let's head on to the
abyss and get some fights going
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
let's just check out the temperatures on
the phone
37 37 38 it goes higher down here
30 39
.
I think it went down just a little bit
on the front but let's check the back
real quick
[Music]
38.6
[Music]
40 down here yeah it hasn't changed as
much the last we checked it so thoughts
on getting impact for the pixel improved
you guys will definitely experience some
pre-made jobs and everything but it's
not that crazy it's very minimal but if
you are kind of anal about that you may
want to consider that when getting this
phone if you're playing genjin
exclusively other thing to note is that
heat is dissipating pretty well across
the back of the phone and even the front
the sides don't feel as hot as compared
to other phones I've reviewed before
so yeah that's it for gentle impact and
let's just move on to the next game
which is Apex but before that here's a
message from our sponsor this video is
brought to you by Asus introducing the
world's first 17-inch OLED foldable
screen the Asus Zenbook 17-fold OLED
features six modes of using the laptop
including laptop mode tablet mode and
desktop mode it offers a laptop
experience like no other with its big
and beautiful 17.3 inch foldable OLED
Nano Edge touch screen and transforms
into a portable 12.5 Powerhouse laptop
when folded great for productivity
enthusiasts okay so after Genji impact
we are now at 94 so the entire
PlayStation 2.6 percent of battery and
right now the temperature on the front
is kind of at like 33 it has cooled down
after just a bit
33.6 let's check the back
34 35 Maybe
no mostly 34.6 yeah so as you can see
like you know heat is being very well
managed by the pixel and pro as I
experienced with Kenshin just now
because you know you usually experience
you know just he coming from just from
one area usually where the chip is at
but this thing so far you know it's it's
pretty spread out it's nice
kind of reminds me of the Asus Rog phone
6 in a way but that was significantly
much cooler because you know there's a
whole thing going on but this thing not
bad and with that let's just get into
Apex Legends
okay let's check the settings real quick
okay extreme HD very high I said all
those things it will take effect in the
next match so that's when later on
everything else VC gone anti-aliasing
Bloom is on everything's on all right
so let's just jump into a match
so far so good
[Applause]
let's go this way
oh we're going there
continue
yeah you know it's a little bit of input
a bit a little bit Lackey in there but I
don't know it's fine
[Applause]
oh wait
another
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
hiring
nice
so you can see that even during the
engagement it doesn't really drop that
much
right now that we're here let's check
the temperatures real quick I can feel
the heating up
it's about 37 to 10 40 ish
you know not too bad still
competitive engine just now
let's check the back
37 obviously you'll get Hector
the bags like 37ish
[Music]
37.8
38.9 39
40 on the top here so yeah you will feel
the heat just a little bit and I'll
squats in danger hold on
where
I do not see the dude oh they were
[Music]
[Applause]
getting one down
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
there you go
thank you
I'm the kill leader ready for bear
yeah not too bad
so yeah we've had enough time with Apex
Legends as Legend and let's just check
the temperatures and then we can move
the next game so for the front
we're doing like 40 37.9 39 ish all the
way
here
you know it's not as bad as genjin and I
think this is where the chip is at let's
see that correlates later when we check
the back
and yeah it's honestly it's it's warm as
hell yes it definitely will be warm
because it's a screen but let's check
the back who wants to see it rain
39.3 39 38
as you can see though it's very nicely
spread out across the phone so it's not
that bad so yeah playing Apex on the
pix7 pro is a definite yes it's pretty
comfortable to play on and you did the
way of your hands getting burnt out or
anything like engine so
yeah let's just move on to the next game
and our guy has it handled so yeah
next game it is
[Applause]
so coming off from Apex Legends we are
at 87 battery so still not too bad and
let's just check temperatures real quick
32 so as you can see no heat dissipates
pretty quickly when you let it rest for
a bit
at the back
yeah pretty uniform I'd say
so yeah with that let's just go into
Call of Duty
what is up with this resolution thing
that is weird
huh
huh
for some reason he does that I'm not
sure why but it did anyway so
um whatever if anyone can explain that
let me know in the comments uh let's see
Graphics are very high let's say to Max
but I don't think we can oh we can okay
cool I'll try multiplayer but the thing
is with ultra we can only go to low
there's no way I can bring it up any
higher
[Music]
okay so uh let's check the settings
graphically we are on high and on Max
for FPS uh obviously I can't put Ultra
because if I put it in Ultra I'll go to
low so I'm not going to do that and I
don't think I can toggle very high
oh I can okay cool
so yeah let's just check our multiplayer
settings turn all of this on
and let's just jump into a match
yes there's no clear way on how to
remove this button so
we'll see
so far so smooth
[Applause]
yeah I will say it's a bit finicky to
get around the controls like this not
really because of the button but just
because I know I don't know why it just
feels kind of weird to play
I think I need to adjust the sensitivity
options but other than that it's fine
so after the match let's check out the
temperatures
36.5 I mean it is Call of Duty so it's
not as fast as it would be compared to
Apex origin
so yeah 37 36 that's pretty decent let's
just check the back
all right so let's check the back
37.837 it's a bit hot down here
39.40
honestly results have been pretty
uniform so far
especially the last two games and this
one it's always like 40ish all across
the ball 38 across the board ish so yeah
it's it's not bad
but let's move on to the next game
which is Diablo Immortal uh we are
currently at 83 battery okay so before
we get into Diablo Immortal let's check
the temperatures real quick note we are
coming in hot off of Call of Duty so the
thing is temperatures may still be
around the same as the last one but just
checking in you know
still at 37 Nation the last time
from the last match about 37 in the back
36 ish 37-ish and I think about 40 on
top
here all 39 Oh yeah oh okay
it's really gone down in temperature
quite a bit already by like a degree or
two but yeah let's just jump into Diablo
Immortal okay cool let's check out the
settings real quick
before that you get out of here
okay settings graphics and let's put it
to 60 yes Ultra is still not supported
on this device so
whatever image opening yo why not and
yeah we've already overloaded the device
so let's go
okay let's do a dungeon real quick
I might as well just use my
trusts
let's go
[Music]
so so far it feels pretty smooth on 60
FPS let's just go for it
okay with my army or skeletons
and we're moving off with my necromancer
someone everyone
[Applause]
haven't noticed any frame rate drops yet
let's just keep moving
oh don't pocket
interesting
[Applause]
yeah to see the extreme rated dropping
quite a bit here because I mean it is
pretty busy
foreign
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
drops
yeah
interesting
[Applause]
nice
so yeah with that let's just check the
temperatures real quick with Diablo and
everything it's not as bad as Apex
against engine
but you know I think it's heating up a
bit more than Call of Duty obviously
and even the sights feel a bit more
warmer compared to Call of Duty the back
is burning up a little bit let's see how
it goes 39 38.
39 about here
somewhere on here
and then there's 38.9 40 on the top
so oh actually it's still pretty much
the same as the other three games
so yeah and this has Call of Duty of
course if I remember right but other
than that wow good job Google when it
comes to heat management it's nice and
spread out it's not like one just not
like one size like 33 and then the other
side is like 49 or 50 that kind of thing
so Google did a really good job when it
comes to heat management
so yeah
um with that let's move on to my final
thoughts this is definitely not a gaming
phone but it is a phone that you can
game on and game with I'd say in
especially in the case of Kenshin impact
where
I mean it's Kenshin so you know it's
gonna be running hot man it's gonna be
running hot especially during prolonged
periods of play time you guys will
definitely feel the heat coming from the
back in the front I've only played for
like 15 minutes so okay if you guys can
imagine an hour that's going to be tough
man that's gonna be really tough so
we've been shooting for the last hour
and we're down about 20 after playing
all four of these games on their highest
set things so I guess I can say that
battery wise it's actually pretty good
and also I had to compliment Google
again because you guys got heat
management pretty right as you can see
like throughout the entire video as I
was checking out the temperatures on the
back it's pretty uniform throughout all
of the games which is pretty cool to see
especially coming from a phone that
isn't meant for gaming you guys pretty
much nailed it out there with this phone
but the real question is will you get a
pixel 7 Pro for yourself let us know in
the comment section down below like this
video subscribe to us and if you like
this kind of content check this out
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]